we'll start by taking a look at the
south of ukraine in the position there
as we are overnight from odessa in the
western maripol in the east michael
clark our defense analyst uh you're with
us today it's day nine what is the state
of play yes paul the russians tried to
do this the clever way and failed so now
they've gone back to the old routine and
we see it in mario paul we've been
talking about this all the time it's the
city's now surrounded they've cut off
the
facilities the water electricity and now
they will pound the city until they
think it's on its knees and then they'll
move in with armor and troops and that
is the model for what they are
threatening to do in the rest of the
country perhaps those worrying
development overnight the apparent
shelling of the zaparizia power station
just near the nipper there europe's
biggest nuclear power station we can see
satellite image of it here the obvious
question why would anyone shell a
nuclear power station we're still
getting about this paul
if it was a strategic decision taken in
the kremlin then presumably president
putin is trying to frighten the rest of
europe like with his nuclear threats
into understanding that this is such a
delicate and dangerous crisis don't mess
with me anymore that might be the case
more likely my view that this is just
strategic stupidity on the part of local
commanders who see the power station
supplies 20 of electricity to ukraine
that's a big facility let's bomb it um
without thinking about the wider
implications that second option there is
perhaps the most frightening the
consequences of a leak or a reactive
failure here would be catastrophic yeah
reactor failure as an explosion fairly
unlikely a leak is quite likely if you
keep bombing a plant and then if there
is a radioactive leak it's subject to
the weather it can go wherever the
weather takes it just as likely to go
back to belarus and russia as anywhere
else absolutely crazy and stupid and it
appears that the ukrainians have
eventually given this facility up in the
interest of the safety not just of their
country but of europe yeah my own view
from what we've known so far i think the
ukrainians essentially surrendered the
plan to the russians to prevent another
chernobyl
uh sobering thought that let's go back
to the map of the south of ukraine if we
can because i know you want to talk
particularly about odessa and the
strategic importance and what the
russian plan might be in the coming days
yeah so dessert and the port near it
actually accounts for about 70 percent
of all of of ukraine's maritime trade if
the russians take odessa in that
coastline which i'm fairly sure they
will then they've cut ukraine off from
sea trade now
you know ukraine can still trade by land
but there's no comparison between what
you can get through on land as opposed
to the tonnages you can get by sea so it
becomes quite a big strategic objective
for the russians so it's economically
important but to the the outcome of what
happens next let's briefly go back to
the north of the country if we can i
think we can take a look at the area
around kievan let's get an update from
you michael on that convoy that huge
convoy of russian ordnance and supply
vehicles that seems to be stuck for the
last few days you've notified noticed
some developments yeah i mean the convoy
hasn't moved for three days but
battalion tactical groups which are the
fighting groups are beginning to fan out
west from it and they're they're into
the west exactly and that's the hardest
place for them because it's full of
natural obstacles water water railroads
and so on but they're moving west
they're beginning to surround kiev it
still takes some time and this convoy is
there to supply these battalion tactical
groups as best we can see it's still a
huge target so they're still taking some
big risks but the this encirclement of
kiev goes on although i don't think it's
going nearly as quickly as the russians
intended
thank you michael they may well have
thought it was over by now uh but
plainly uh on day nine uh this is the
beginning of just a long haul